saya player was one of overwatch's
greatest dps stars just taking another
angle oh my god
oh there we go
triple kill from him the huge plays
just tubing up get out valiant but after
his team struggled to find success on
the game's biggest stage
his future looked bleak so it was really
bad situation for me so
at that time i lose a passion a little
bit valorent re-ignited saya's desire to
compete and he is ready to shine once
again
here comes the anime battle
get out of here we talk about the push
down towards garage so it's a one for
one blank storm farcia player cloud
burst in the front of sight a double
swing for the attackers here in the
front and what a shot here
still dancing around this cage down to
25 hp tripwire on his way to dashing
what are you doing say a player
a red bull clutch out of literally
nowhere i can't believe it that is
outrageous sire
hey folks before we get into the video i
just want to tell you all to please sub
to the channel and turn on notifications
if you haven't done it yet because it
really does help
okay so some of you might have only
recently heard of saya player he's one
of the most exciting jet players in n a
and his performances for the guard have
helped the team break into tier one
valorent but his journey to stardom
began long before valrant see before the
game even came out saya was one of
overwatch's most exciting dps players
he's gotta be your priority number one
right now and look at it he's just
taking another angle oh my god
oh there we go saya triple kill from him
the huge plays
just tombing up get out valiant
so sick sire
well this is an example of how to hard
carry ladies and gentlemen there you go
cya player so how exactly did saya
player go from being one of the owl's
biggest stars to becoming one of
valoran's newest breakout sensations
well to answer that we have to go all
the way back to 2016 when sciplayer was
17 deep into soccer and discovering
blizzard's new hero shooter in his home
country korea after losing his passion
for soccer saya player became obsessed
with overwatch and quickly decided that
he wanted to go pro he believed that as
long as he put in the work he'd break
into korea's tier 1 overwatch scene and
by early 2017 he was popping off for
meta athena in ogn's overwatch apex
season 2. now he's going to poke his
head up they are going to be able to see
what this composition is oh
a dear mess
sci-fi is so so close as soon as carpe
was out there it seemed like he knew
exactly oh there it is maybe the first
and multiple
working on that diva shield there's a
shot of the man himself going for the
mid-air shots now oh
[Music]
mercy as well he is carrying this fight
flashy plays quickly caught the eyes of
the florida mayhem in the newly formed
overwatch league
so initially we were looking for someone
that had incredibly raw talent and
mechanical skill
which saya player really fit that bill
mayhem fans were dying to see him play
and in his first week of matches he gave
them a taste of what to expect
that was actually i think a three or
four person flashbang unfortunately
despite all of saya players talents the
mayhem just couldn't beat the league's
top teams their poor form continued into
stage four and by the end of the season
they missed out on playoffs but the one
shining star throughout all their
struggles was saya player everyone you
know that he's your pocket you know that
he's the carry and everyone's in on the
action and that's why
he makes it look so easy
unbelievable
just not missing a single shot all
headshots all headshots eqo drops
dangerously low however probably a bit
of a volley there coming in from zoupe
there you go cya player rewarded with
one follows it up on a kill and now he's
looking to cut him off as they retreat
sure enough there it is boombox is dead
zaya player
so good oh yeah let's take a look at
this right before that final point comes
up the shot on the birding that is so
filthy there
his performances in the final two stages
of the season earned him a spot in the
league's first ever all-star weekend
alongside some of the best players in
the world it was a nice distraction from
his team's struggles but the mayhem
needed to make a drastic change if they
wanted to qualify for the season 2
playoffs
unfortunately the losses just kept
piling up
it doesn't really matter as soon as the
transcendence expires it might just be
it bubbles
down the ground that's good though it's
going to be taken out
going down the beat comes in dynasty can
they actually do it
he gets the right click against all odds
they look to turn this one around the
shatter comes through zephyr trying to
beat them down he'll get knocked up into
the air the lt plummets away and oh my
god florida may have a one player
advantage going into the next stage of
the fight sorry played out dragon open
has he done it again he might have
bailed him out he's got rid of chris and
now is it for going down to sinatra
the florida miami pushed off the payload
in new york excel on the defense it is
looking like it's all coming together
for them florida and mayhem they tried
their hearts out today but it just
wasn't enough new york excel an elite
top three team in the league
sciplayer was still popping off but the
mayhem finished the season at the bottom
of the table once again and in 2019 saya
player's days as one of the best dps
players in the league came to a grinding
halt the meta was changing hitscan
characters fell out of favor and teams
were running triple tank and triple
healer team comps which left saya player
riding the bench for a lot of the season
or sometimes flexing onto heroes that he
wouldn't normally play so i can't play
any defense
hero so it was really bad situation for
me so
at that time i lose a passion a little
bit because because of meta by the end
of the year heroes like hanzo and
widowmaker made their way back into the
meta but the damage was already done
saya player had fallen out of love with
the game so with his overwatch days
behind him in april 2020 saya turned his
eyes to a new challenge
isil ballarant came out and i like
i used to be like
csgo kind of cs go games so i want to
try it saya player wanted to go pro
again so he grinded valorant non-stop
and by october 2020 he was offered a
spot on t1 now in the early days of
valorent t1 was one of the most exciting
rosters in the game they had brax
skadoodle dazed and azk it was basically
an ibuypower cs go reunion and with a
korean aim god rounding out their roster
fans had high hopes for t1 and saya was
excited to play alongside some of the
big names he looked up to from the cs go
scene i didn't play
professional but i watched a csgo
matches so i i already know them so it
was really
a good experience for me
and i really excited because i i really
don't play tactical fps before so
i think i can get a lot of experience
from them saya player changed his name
to spider he started playing mostly omen
and jet for t1 and once qualifiers for
riot's first big domestic tournament got
underway he popped off immediately time
is of the essence and that is the fifth
player the sixth player in the lobby but
unfortunately for them so is spiders
they get caught in the weft the venom
strikes all down to player one and
spider will take him down and spider
quick snappy headshot oh one second from
spider the third don is able to take
care of one of the anchors as kuman
takes care of the other one as well
spiders one of the last ones standing
the rolling thunders used spider trying
to stay alive somehow he's able to win
that fight he's dropping down to 1v1
he's got the phantom and he clutches it
out spider with a serious impact for t1
spiders performance helped t1 qualify
for first strike but their tournament
run was cut short after a loss in the
opening round to the eventual winners
hundred thieves
what a huge fight by austin and hiko
closes out the match through the phoenix
wall
a hundred
taking it over t1 what a fight it was
they fought so damn hard so many
clutches you could see the preparation
from both teams they both played so damn
well it's heartbreaking to see one of
these two teams exiting the tournament
but
i mean we have to give it to both of
them they played it so well sure this
wasn't the result that t1 wanted but
qualifying for first strike had to be a
good sign
at least
that's what everyone thought
the vandal says you're done one player
left is all on spider three versus one
this is gonna be the tallest of orders
this completely keep him in the vct it's
not gonna happen defenders t1 going down
to unboxing that best of three going the
whole nine yards two one final score and
top 16 t1 they're gonna be out 2021
proved to be a disaster for t1 they were
losing but more importantly the roster
was a revolving door first automatic
joined from csgo followed by curry then
brax left to join tsm only to return a
few months later then a few months after
that days got dropped the roster changed
every couple of months making it
difficult for the team to build any sort
of chemistry by the end of 2021 spider
decided it was time to leave t1 and also
change his name back to saya player
luckily for him a new roster was forming
just as he entered free agency owned by
the same company as the overwatch
league's la gladiators the guard wanted
to build a top tier valorent roster in n
a and once matt elmore joined as the
team's head coach he immediately gave
saya a trial there were a couple
different duelists that i wanted to
trial
and they had brought in saya to trial as
a flex player
whenever we scrimmed them on jinji the
only time i felt like t1 ever competed
with us was when zai was on jet on like
icebox and stuff and he would just drop
40 on us
and so i knew
he was extremely capable as a jet offer
and like he was very very difficult to
deal with at times and like i wanted to
bring saya back in
to trial as a jet the guard recognized
that saya player had something special
and they signed him in december 2021
despite the fact that his competitive
history invalorant was
shaking and with some of the best jet
knives in na saya player was ready to do
some damage
what a wacky round i don't think they're
gonna be ready for saya and spawn either
he finds one it's so clean here comes
the anime battle
dish up high oh
get out of here ahead of the 2022 vct
season the guard got some practice at
various online events and added trend to
their roster for extra firepower once
the open qualifiers got underway saya
player and the guard proved that they
were a team to fear they're not really
in there yet because we already had a
fast rotation going in for the defense
exactly with the shock dart a recon
guard i had to come out at the same time
and it's going to be a crew that still
has the advantage side player though
with this bull that we mentioned before
bites the first one barks for the second
and will he get this one he won and he
will for the red bull clutch himself to
make it 11 to 8 for the guard we talk
about the push down towards garage so
it's a one for one blank storm farcia
player cloud burst in the front of sight
a double swing for the attackers here in
the front and what a shot here from cyan
player two daggers in the face of calm
and pancakes and that's gonna be the
guard at that point and we've got a
bunch of traits going in trance on a two
versus one looking to clutches but the
spike is down cosmic divided on the
defender's side he's trying to hold back
towards the sidewalk a lean out for the
first goal what election with the
pancakes and it's going to be the guard
winning this 13-7 and trent the clutch
player for the red bull clutch
sia and his team popped off their
performance earned them a spot in the
vct challengers group stage among some
of na's best it was a story of being
able to bring a team together for for a
really long time now and just make sure
that it was a team that gelled and
they have gelled themselves into the vct
but saya player didn't just make an
impact on the server with plenty of
esports experience his young teammates
now look up to him he knows what it
takes to compete at the highest level
and has the mentality you'd expect from
a korean pro player so i respect him a
lot for the fact that he knows what it
takes to be one of the best i'm trying
to just like try to be a sponge and just
learn as much as i can for him because
he's very professional what he does and
i think what makes him better what gives
him that edge is that he's just
mechanically on a another level compared
to like a lot of the players in the
scene and he's a pretty selfless player
he's willing to do anything he can to
win so i respect that a lot you know
he's a competitor he he genuinely wants
to get better and he puts an effort uh
to do so and i i really respect that
about players like that sia player and
the guard have proven that they're one
of the best teams in north america after
facing off against some of the region's
top dogs week in and week out you can't
say they're not the real deal and after
competing at the top of overwatch and
valorant over the last six years it's
pretty clear that saya player is
something special too he went from
grappling on widowmaker to updrafting
with jet and no matter who he played for
along the way he always showed up but
this time is different the burden of
carrying his teams isn't there like it
has been for most of his career
alongside some of na's best young talent
this korean superstar finally has the
support that he deserves and next week
once the challenger's main event kicks
off saya will finally get a chance at
qualifying for his first ever
international lan in valorant thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring the
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
us up on our twitter instagram facebook
and tick talk
[Music]